ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه يعني الحديث في اكسس عن تخفيض
الحرب لانه كلمه وقف الحرب مكلفه سياسيا
في اسرائيل وفي الولايات المتحده هل تعتقد
ان هذا هو
المخرج ل مازق نتنياهو
وبايدن هو ليس مخرج ولكن تاكيد على الفشل
تقليص الحرب و في نفس الوقت تغيير الخطط
الاسرائيليه كما تحدث حتى رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي كل ذلك يدل على فشل عميق
للعمليه الاسرائيليه بايدن منح اسرائيل 81
يوم لتحقق اهدافها فشلت في كل شيء فشلت في
التطهير العرقي الذي كانت تؤيده الولايات
المتحده في بدايه
العدوان بسبب صمود الشعب الفلسطيني فشلت
وفشلت في اقتلاع المقاومه التي ما زالت
قويه وشديده وفي كل المناطق وفشلت في فرض
السيطره الاحتلال على المناطق التي دخلتها
وفشلت في استعاده الاسرى وهذا كان هدف
مركزي للعدوان الجاري اذا فشل كامل ويضاف
الى ذلك تعقيد الوضع الاسرائيلي بسبب
الخسائر البشريه العاليه وخسائر اقتصاديه
هائله وانحطاط معنوي ناتج عن التحول
العالمي ضد اسرائيل كل ه العوامل تؤكد ان
هناك فشل وبالتالي بايدن الان يت ردد في
منحهم طائرات الاباتشي لسببين اولا لانهم
فشلوا وهو يخشى انه اعطائهم مزيد من
الطائرات لن يؤدي الا الى فشل اخر وثانيا
لان بايدن اليوم يشعر بانه سيخسر
الانتخابات
القادمه الان اصبحت الصوره واضحه هو خسر
حتى تاييد الشعب الامريكي او معظم الشعب
الامريكي لدعمه لاسرائيل
وبالتالي هذا سبب ايضا مهم لتردده في
اعطائهم مزيد من السلاح ولكن هذا لا يعني
انه انتقل الى النقطه التي يجب ان يصل
اليها وهو وقف العدوان و وتاييد وقف اطلاق
النار مازال يدعم اسرائيل ولكن موقفه الان
يعكس احساسه بالفشل الفشل الاسرائيلي
العمي طيب هل هل هذا هذا ال هذه المواقف
الجريده سواء في البيت الابيض او في حتى
صانع السياسه الاسرائيلي هل يمكن
استثمارها كيف يمكن استثمارها من جانب
الفلسطينيين يمكن استثمارها بشكل فعال
بامرين الامر الاول التمسك بالموقف الحازم
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بانه لا تبادل للاسرى
دون وقف شامل لاطلاق النار دون وقف
العدوان على كل قطاع غزه وقف هذه العمليه
الاجراميه التي تمس بحياه الناس وتمس
بالاطفال والنساء والرجال يجب ان يتم وقف
اطلاق النار وقف العدوان بالكامل وعدم
التنازل عن هذا الموقف والان الظروف مهي
لذلك لان غالبيه دول العالم تؤيد الوقف
الكامل والشامل لاطلاق النار فورا و 1553
دوله صوتت معه جميع دول في مجلس الامن
باستثناء الولايات المتحده التي صوتت ضده
وبريطانيا التي امتنعت هناك تحول عام في
الراي العام يؤكد صحه الموقف بانه لا شيء
يمكن ان يحدث الا بوقف كامل لاطلاق النار
الامر الثاني يجب الان توحيد الموقف
الفلسطيني لسد الطريق على كل شخص يريد ان
يعبث بالساحه الفلسطينيه ويريد ان يلعب
لعبه فرق تسود توحيد الموقف الفلسطيني على
جبهه وطنيه موحده تتبنى نهج الكفاح
والمقاومه ضد هذا الاحتلال وتتبنى توحيد
الصف الوطني والتاكيد على ان غزه لا تفصل
عن الضف الغربيه ولا عن اي ارض فلسطينيه
اخرى باعتبارها مكون له نشكرك شكرا جزيلا
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ضيفنا من رام
الله